hey guys it is Friday which means I'm
here to fill you in on all the biggest
things that have happened in gaming this
week dan you want to be in this episode
no thanks yes I'll let you talk about
River succeed all right okay everyone's
favorite long-running multiplayer
centric tactical first-person shooter
based on a book received a bunch of
announcements this week Ubisoft
announced that the first of Rainbow six
siege is a year to new content operation
velvet shell will launch on februari 7
for ps4 xbox one and pc the new
operation takes players to the shores of
abita where they will fight their way
through the new la polla blanca resort
the two new operators jackal and mirror
will also teased this week jackals
unique ability appears to be a
head-mounted display that allows him to
track enemy footsteps on the ground
while mirror is capable of blowing holes
in reinforced walls rather than
destroying them completely as with all
previous siege content maps are free for
all players and the new operators are
available through the $30 year 2 season
pass if you're still arming and iring
about whether or not to jump into
rainbow 6 siege you can play the full
version for free right now until
februari 5th or 6th depending on your
platform instructor new info on Star
Wars Bell front to CEO andrew wilson
explained that battlefront 2 will be
even bigger than the 2015 original and
will feature more locations and hero
characters yay also officially confirmed
that as expected the game will feature a
single player campaign Wilson added
battlefront 2 will feature content from
multiple star wars errors and that the
game will be developed by dice motive
studios and criterion next up pretty
soon you'll be able to breach the walls
of piranha when it goes into open beta
get it because it's like breaching the
walls and it's like medieval warfare and
immediately before it launches on
februari 14 and open beta will run from
februari 9 to 12 on pc xbox one and ps4
the beta features four modes elimination
Dominion brawl and jewel the full game
contains five modes and twelve heroes or
the beta only has nine heroes Ubisoft
previously ran a closed beta for for
honor between january 26 to 29
earlier this week Xbox boss Phil Spencer
allayed fears that the more powerful
project Scorpio is going to make the
Xbox one obsolete Spencer clarified on
Twitter that xbox one and xbox one s
will be supported by microsoft for many
years to come project Scorpio is drew
out during the holiday period of this
year and is intended to be a higher-end
option that complements the Xbox one
it's a very similar relationship to what
Sony appeared to be aiming for between
ps4 and PS 4 pro Spencer has also made
recent comments that development on
Scorpio is coming along great and he
said that he was impressed after playing
games on the console for the first time
it seems you guys a massive fans of
classic consoles as Nintendo has
revealed that 1.5 million NES classic
edition consoles have been sold across
the globe nope that's the old one
nintendo president atsumichi Mishima
also addressed the widespread shortages
that have plagued the sixty dollar NES
classic edition he explained that some
of the reason why replenishing stock is
taking a long time is because it quote
some parts required time to procure but
Nintendo is working to increase
production to meet demand in regards to
what it means for the switch he added we
also see the nostalgic interest in these
products as an opportunity to draw
consumers attention to our latest game
system Nintendo switch the NES classic
edition comes with 30 games and sold out
almost immediately when it arrived in
November this week on site check out our
review in progress for neo we tell you
if the first DLC for resident evil 7 is
worth your time and we take a look at
the new landslide mission in hitman
[Music]